the most important thing in sales number
one above everything and this is a
strong statement for me to say is frame
the context under which the conversation
is happening so you can be the most
skilled salesperson in the world and you
will sell less than somebody who has a
line out the door because of how much
value they've provided every single
person in that line it doesn't matter if
you're the best person in the world
fewer people will buy from you if
they've never met you you've provided
nothing to them if you're trying to sell
more learning all the mechanics of sales
overcomes Etc is worthwhile is important
but you're missing the biggest one which
is you build brand you provide value
first so that you don't have to